Donald Trump's first visit to India's
capital coincided with the worst violent
protests against the government's
citizenship law since it was passed in
December before he arrived White House
staff said the president would raise
concerns with Prime Minister Narendra
Modi about the law
critics condemned as anti-muslim but
Trump didn't seem too concerned when he
spoke to reporters the prime minister
was incredible on what he told me he
wants people to have religious freedom
and very strongly and he said that in
India India they have they have worked
very hard to have great and open
religious freedom Trump said he didn't
discuss the latest in three months of
protests happening just 15 kilometers
away in the suburbs of the capital he
was keen to emphasize the Sayed of three
billion dollars worth of military
equipment to India even though the
Deegan was expected we expanded our
defense cooperation with agreements for
India to purchase more than three
billion dollars of advanced American
military equipment the sale of US
military helicopters was the one big
takeaway from the trip how mighty Tamir
hominy we discussed every aspect of our
partnership including defense security
energy strategic partnership and
technology cooperation our growing
defence and security cooperation is a
vital part of our strategic partnership
but there was no progress on the biggest
sticking point between two of the
world's largest economies a
comprehensive trade deal we've had a
massive massive deficit but a large
deficit 30 billion dollars with India
it's now down to 24 billion dollars
because of what we've been doing but
still let's do hi we shouldn't have a 24
billion dollar deficit both leaders said
they were hopeful of reaching a deal
soon the u.s. president returns home
boasting about selling billions of
dollars worth of military hardware to
secure American jobs nine months
for his bid for re-election while
India's Prime Minister received nothing
but praise from Trump when he's facing
criticism at home and abroad for his
Hindu nationalist government's
citizenship law and mistreatment of
Indian Muslims Elizabeth puranam al
Jazeera New Delhi